What do you think is the next big
breakthrough that's going to change in terms of like how technology
and people get along?
He's going to be a robot sex tall.
No,
I think home home,
uh,
assistance,
you know,
like having a robot couldn't be your home base,
like computer.
Uh,
I dunno like these Alexis and I'll like Apple's about to release Thurs and
Google has released authors and have seen the autonomous robots that monitor
parking lots now.
Yeah,
I tweeted it I think yesterday,
but definitely robots.
We're going to give up our security and all our privacy at the same time.
Hmm.
We're going to be fine because the robot's going to be watching us keep an eye
on me.
Robot.
This is going to be zero privacy.
Zero.
It's real close.
It's already there.
But I mean real close to not just regular zero privacy,
but like no one ever has a moment alone ever.
It doesn't exist anymore.
Like it will slowly erode.
Then you'd go into the mountains in the put cell phone towers out there and then
that's going to be it.
Whatever the technology is it's going to be,
you're going to know where everyone is at any moment and we're going to really
get to know each other.
What do you got Jamie?
I was looking up for the thing I saw.
I saw it.
It wasn't on your Twitter feed.
I guess I saw a video of like autonomous parking robots,
building cars in and out of spots.
I didn't put it on Twitter.
I thought I did shit.
Um,
it was uh,
a comp.
Appreciate.
I retweeted it.
You know what it does though I think are retweeted somebody else saying,
hey,
this is happening or something like that.
So it's probably not that clear.
One of the more recent tweets
tapping and Brian,
they're going to be flying around us monitoring us.
You saw that one robot,
I think it was in San Francisco.
Eat Up homeless people or something like that.
Could move and stuff like that happens.
There's going to be a big pull back.
It's crazy.
Robots fucking need.
We need robots picking on the downtrodden.
That's good move.
Let them know you post.
These are on your way out.
The robots are here.
I mean that literally is like the first wave of immigrants from the silicone
world.
Robots at fuck with homeless people.
The first,
the first invaders tripping him and stuff.
I robot.
The thing about I robot as you'd watch it and it was,
it was made just at the right time.
It was made where you didn't think it's ever possible.
It's made at a time.
Well this is pretty cool.
Like yeah man,
the future.
Yeah.
I could see it being real,
but you didn't think it was really possible and now you watch I robot and you
go,
oh,
it's inevitable.
That's inevitable.
That thing that does the robot thing would it pretends to be a person and looks
real freaky.
That's easily doable.
Yakima or what's at Machinima?
What's that one?
There is hot shit it security robots are using are being used to ward off San
Francisco's homeless population.
That's the drug.
What's it called?
Who makes that thing say they retired it?
Yeah.
Oh they did.
Because there's a,
there's a whole company that makes those things and has them like wandering
around parking lots.
And Man,
I hope I retweeted it.
I tried to,
um,
somebody sent it to me and I was like,
okay.
That's how it happens.
They just have these things wandering around,
recording everything.
So everybody's responsible for any car accident.
Anything that ever happens,
if it hears is someone's screaming rape.
If it hears someone's screening police and immediately goes to the scene and
films,
there's no worries about its own mortality.
It's streaming in real time.
It gets to record all altercations between people.
Eventually hotels agree.
As long as this is password secure and encrypted,
they allowed to have the fire detector in the corner double as a video camera
that records everything in the room at all times.
What's going to happen.
Yeah,
I agree.
Just got to get used to people watching you fuck
and ready.
I took the sticker off my webcam on my laptop a long time ago.
Oh,
Joe.
They can watch me all I want.
I don't know why I'm more nervous about this in 2018 this is what's silly.
I mean,
it's become accelerated.
Like I,
I'm more nervous every year when it comes to technology because I'm not nervous
in a,
in a way that I think it's totally 100% negative but nervous in a way.
Like it just seems to me that we might be in the middle of something and not be
paying attention like it,
that it's happening so fucking fast that we're caught up in it and it's just
this wild wave of change.
And I'm just trying to make sense of it while it's happening.
But then there's something about like numbers,
like I used to think that saying like the year 2017 2000 it's a stupid,
who cares what year it is?
It's all just now.
But no,
there's like a way we feel about it differently.
Like you,
oh,
it's fucking 2018 dude,
dude.
It's like you have a feeling about you now.
It's like we're,
we're very,
very far ahead in this game.
This is,
this is the future.
2018 that's a crazy number.
Hey Man,
it's 1979 nope,
it's 2018 whoa.
So weird.
And when does this thing like if you had a gas,
how much longer does the human race have?
Six months.
It seems like you really,
if you really had to guess,
we're not going to be here forever.
Right?
So we're not going to be here a hundred thousand years from now or 200,000 years
from now.
We're just not.
I started listening to the audio book of Sapiens.
Yeah,
and that's,
I feel like that's what it's getting to.
That question you're asking is the first couple of chapters are leading up to
like he says it over and over again like thousands of years from now.
Maybe 2000 is what it's saying that the human race won't be or human beings
won't be what we are.
We'll be another
evolution of whatever that is because I'm off of Australia.
[inaudible]
Australia.
Pithiest see if you find any good pictures of that thing.
I mean this is what they think.
They think that that that's what started it.
That was when it was like fairly distinctly human.
It's gonna.
It's gonna keep going.
It's going to go to some new thing,
right?
There it is.
Look at that thing.
I mean,
that's so close.
It's what?
Like a walking upright chimpanzee and then that got smarter and that got smarter
and things kept going,
but the thing that really fucks you up is,
it's not that long ago.
I think Australia.
Perfect.
This was less than 2 million years,
right?
Sounds right.
And then there's a modern homo sapiens,
which I think they think are somewhere in the neighborhood of 300 to 500,000
years old.
They keep moving it around a little bit.
When they find some new dead guy,
I find some new bones and they're like,
oh,
this one's older.
They got to,
they're kind of guessing.
I want to say they're in the neighborhood of 300,000 that ain't shit,
dude.
That ain't shit.
That just happened.
If that's when they really started.
So you're talking about 300,000 years from now.
Ooh,
it's crazy.
We're going to be made out of gas.
We're going to be like those fires that aren't petroleum.
We won't be able to see us are intelligent to be all pervasive.
We'll we'll have one operating system that we share with mother earth.
They'll plug it into our brains will plug into the ground and we'll will become
divine.
How about that?
No,
I don't know.
No one's here.
That's how I am like that.
I'm going just told him he'll come back,
but I always wonder what they thought about this 200 years ago.
150 years ago,
what they thought are we,
I feel like they had thought that the world was gonna end to back then.
Yeah,
but he's always talking years away from it ending.
Sure.
I mean anytime.
Anything,
especially back when there was no media,
anytime anything catastrophic happened in your area,
you thought that was going to be the end.
Okay.
The moon was made of cheese.
It's,
it's really weird how recent that was.
That's what's weird.
When you just think about hundreds of thousands years,
it seems like a long ass time,
but it's not.
When you talk,
talk about the shape of human beings and what what's happened in that amount of
time,
especially in the last few hundred or few thousand years,
just all you need is sick.
If you want to like really impress the shit out of people,
give me 10,000 years,
10,000 years ago,
10,000 years now you're like,
wow,
you'd freak out.
There's no other time in history.
That would be the case.
Like every other time in history,
10,000 years would be like,
whoa,
all they figured out how to make cooler houses.
Like,
Whoa,
he's riding an elephant.
How do you figure that out?
Like,
Whoa,
all that bone Arrow is way better than my bow and Arrow every 10,000 years.
It's no big deal.
And then all of a sudden,
one 10,000 year period and you have everything,
you got the pyramids,
you got space travel,
you've got the internet,
you've got video photography,
three d printers.
Every time you say something like this,
this uh,
pops in my head,
the end of gangs in New York where it shows that montage of the hundred years or
so of New York changing.
Nice.
Think about how that's only a hundred years in New York changed from this crazy
nothingness,
even though it's really big then to like tons of skyscrapers and bridges and all
of what it is today and it wasn't any,
anything close to that back then.
And that's like what a hundred years and you're talking about 10,000
well,
that's so much more time compared to a hundred yeah.
That's an amazing montage.
Timelapse what would you call that?
That's time lapse.
Look at that.
That's incredible.
New York City's a freak out man,
and even more crazy look at that.
It keeps going.
Yeah.
And that's even bigger now.
Oh my God.
And towers aren't there.
Okay.
Yeah.
New York City is a genuine freak out.
Unless you've been,
you should go.
Okay.
If you've been in,
you get it,
you're like,
yeah,
it's not so love gone.
But if you haven't been,
it's a paradigm shifter because you realize that it's possible.